these are the latest migrants to make
the journey from Turkey to lesbos
it's a perilous crossing made in search
of passage to Europe the hope of a new
start in fact this is what awaits them
recent arrivals have been stopped from
applying for asylum here instead they're
loaded onto a military vessel it's
expected to take them to a detention
center on the mainland and then probably
deportation migrations the abiding theme
on this island and the contrast comes
from another boat
the Mari LeBaron is a hundred and three
years old it's crewed by volunteers it
roams the waters around lesbos in search
of refugees monitoring how the Coast
Guard responds we're joining them for a
day heckled as we board by a group of
protesters in their opinion this boat
promotes migration the anger overt we
leave harbor early and in a hurry
if the crew sees a migrant vessel they
alert the Coast Guard sometimes it is
too late I do know that these people of
these boats can can think quite a fast
people can fall overboard and people can
die I've seen people being dead and
being drowned and that's something that
my hope always tries to yeah try to hope
that it's not happening they claim some
official vessels are deliberately
unhelpful to migrants by pushing their
boats back towards Turkish water or even
damaging the dinghies
and they're trying to get us to move the
port and there is hostility to towards
this charity earlier this week a group
of men approached the boat when it was
moored in harbour petrol was thrown onto
the wooden deck they were told to leave
we have been attacked many journalists
have been attacked and NGO stopped their
work because they thought it was too
dangerous and for especially in this
situation for sure we really had this
feeling of what can we even change like
there's so many things that like so
global that here what can we do so the
moral abarim has finished its voyage in
the channel between Turkey and lesbos we
haven't seen any migrant boat so we're
heading back to miscellany which is that
the biggest town but we've just been
told that we're not actually allowed to
enter the harbor at the moment because
of fears of protests and reprisal
attacks by people who see this boat as a
focal point for their anger against
migrants coming on to this island so for
the moment we've been told to wait
outside we're in a kind of limbo
eventually a compromise
the crew are told to take the team from
Sky News to a different Harbor two hours
away when we arrive that flash of light
is the symbol that it's safe to land we
disembark but it's a brief stop the
marina bearer moves off into the night
a ship for desperate migrants itself in
search of safety Adam Parsons Sky News
lesbos